elle est revenue fatou j'ai failli vous
appelez pas besoin alors prolongé elle
est bloquée au pays elle revient
vendredi prochain mais dire non non le 4
vendredi 4 au 10 416 comme si vraiment
tu commences à comprendre
[Applaudissements]
il va falloir qu'ils arrêtent combat
si si c'est pas bon mais j'arrivais par
la junte ce week-end à bras-panon jeune
et j'ai failli vous demander conseil bah
vous auriez dû et vous auriez dit pas
baba faites-moi la conversation j'ai
appelé moi à l'eau cyril bonjour
[Rires]
comment jean où
j'ai su gérer je suis désolé de te
déranger parce que je sais que tu es
très occupés et a plein de choses à
faire mais j'ai un petit soucis et moi
je n'ai plus aucune nouvelle de fate est
normal et à la maison
pourquoi c'est à dire aucune je suis un
peu inquiet parce que sur what's app
elle répond pas j'envoie des messages
écrits elle répond pas je me demande ce
qui se passe ça fait combien de temps ça
fait trois jours que je n'ai plus un mot
c'est un sonné et c'est la puce nec
[Rires]
donner les coordonnées de champion c'est
son petit ami
jerry west histoire je suis pas encore
inquiet mais je me noie tu n'as pas eu
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui j'ai eu
brièvement et elle refait les papiers
administratifs
et après ça
vous avez à faire c'est réglé c'est vrai
que je leur dit non mais les fautes
l'histoire de la terre je pense qu'il ya
anguille sous roche mère et que l'on dit
c'est pas dit gilles à l'élection qui
pense que j'ai connu
ça que vous
tous je suis obligé pour toi que je le
faire non mais attends
ça vous fait plaisir
[Rires]
g
[Applaudissements]
tulipes roses avec toi que tu es pas
dans la seconde où tu n'es pas alors
elle est très chaleureuse mais comme
elle parle en wolof gen con prof
aubin cgt
cocu ma gueule
c'est un débat qui n'a qu'elle commence
à bayonne
je veux bien michael soutiennent pas
john donc j'ai vous mariez conseiller si
vous avez alors je vous dis moi je vous
conseille tout de suite
sincèrement sincèrement nom adresse qu
un ciel si vous l'appelez la réponse oui
mais oui maman
tu parle wolof
bien sûr non mais c'est quand même
curieux non elle est restée sur les gars
préparer le mariage comprend furie mais
je vois je crois que ça avec quelqu'un
d'autre
tu vois que tu vas voir le voyage matin
à notre regard mais là le contact et
renault et là je vais aller la chercher
vendredi et là on reprend comme un
vote 9 vous réponds pas pour trois jours
c'est bon parce que c'est pas plus
c'est des mots mais voilà une
fois de temps en temps non non non non
non mais ça va entre nous c'est non non
ça ce franchement ça se gagne et là tu
appelles tu as besoin de trois jours et
a dit quoi comment comment le mais quand
tu dis tu étais où es tu te dis quoi
elle me dit j'avais à faire ou non mais
les antilles comme tout
[Rires]
ouais c'est vrai débat c'est vrai elle
aurait pu faire la technique de
retourner la situation oui tu me demande
toujours ce qu est ce que je te prends
toutes les toiles la confiance puisque
c'est comme ça c'est terminé
retourner la situation ses bras
l'expérience
tu me tues mesure fait c'est
inadmissible et dire qu'on était sûr que
le sénégal c'est sur steam d'heure j'ai
vu une femme qui lui ressemble il
s'appelle to fakie charles est un
gourmand dans sa région
[Applaudissements]
la région
tufano s'est extrait de body comment ça
va ça va génial c'est vrai j'ai ton
forme pour moi c'est ça que j les cocus
parce que vous êtes la plus gentille que
j'étais là doit donc kelly avec vos mots
comment pour les irakiens
de se tromper bah moi jle je t'aime de
tout mon coeur brisé mais pas tous aussi
comment et j'aime faut aussi on la voit
moins mais on aime autant bah oui où la
balle à moi parce
qu'on galère et dans le bonheur et joie
et jour j luz on adore
mais là ya un problème un problème balla
ya clairement un problème gilles s'il te
plaît enfin j'ai toujours été là pour
toi et je lâche un moment donné quand on
est amis on se dit les choses serré de
la toujours dit quand on est amis on se
dit les choses oui et moi je pense
sincèrement vous fait peur là je sais
rien mais moi je sais plus quoi dire moi
car ce qu'il vous faut s'ouvrir à votre
nouvelle relation voilà c'est un autre
type de relation c'est pas une relation
habituelle et on se dira je pense
surtout à et fatou oui vous êtes
clairement dans un couple libre à
lui encore nathalie bertin mais vous
êtes libre ça
lui alors je pense que chez vous c'est
mieux de rien se dire voilà elle est
partie que cinq jours trois jours quatre
jours
en fait vous rester trois jours sans
nouvelles s'est bien faut pas poser de
questions si tu poses des questions tu
la mets dans la jauge pas été tuées dans
la merde as tu la laisses faire sa vie
toi pendant ce temps là tout en profite
pour faire la crise qu'elle dégage si il
y a donc ce fameux jean-charles au sein
du domicile et marssac donc jean charles
jean chaque parent chantilly tranquille
on à matane est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fait
si éric de s'allonger
les a mais je pense que c'est la
meilleure chose à faire pour
l'existence spirituelle accord ignorait
il faut ignorer ben là c'est
pourquoi vous ce week-end j'ai été tout
seul personne voulait j'ai trouvé
personne pour être avec moi
ton erreur a pas cherché quand même oui
et personne n'a répondu et j'ai marché
tout seul dans les vignes
[Rires]
je voyais ma peau mais j'ai failli mais
je veux pas vous déranger attendent chez
moi le week-end prochain
réaliste on est samedi après-midi
temps merveilleux
14 heures samedi après midi au téléphone
sonne et s'inscrire gilbert d'aix
j'aurais pu chauffer de l'eau à
décrocher oui j'aurais décroche parce
que je manquais la paix qu'est ce que
vous lui dites bas il va me dire qu'est
ce que tu me dis mathy propose - bonjour
série la loge
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est un petit peu seul et ce que
ce week-end par un petit créneau pour
moi on pourrait boire un verre faire une
marche aller dans les vignes regarder
les moutons ce que tu as envie de faire
cyril ça me ferait tellement plaisir je
veux dire que j'ai envie de faire j
surtout pas envie de te voir
la chope à dole a renchéri mais il
rappelle moi le carioca
mimi n'oublions
pas douter alors un haka cotchery n'y a
pas d'urgence dont tu es tout seul tu es
tout seul j'ai trouvé personne mais pas
très bien mais m'a très bien
roger le roux tél bon alors qu'eddy vous
êtes tiré la sonnette d'alarmé sur la
sonnette d'alarmé mais c'est parce que
je pense que ça peut être positif pour
les personnes qui se rendent à
l'évidence alors qu'elle se rende à
l'évidence c'est bien ce qu'a dit dans
chaque cocu il y à du positif
le positif c'est qu'une fois que tu les
intégrer et battu prend la vie du bon
côté
c'est vrai sachant qu'il est s'il doit
rester ou doit partir à biberist
libre tu pourras ton copain libre mais
ça va pas non
des jaloux il est jaloux tu étais pas si
c'est pas encore prêt psychologiquement
mais il va s'y faire corps avec le temps
parce qu'il est amoureux d'elle alors il
va rester avec elle c'est la vie a fait
la sienne mais celle là elle est là
quand elle n'est pas là bas il se pose
pas de question jean-charles existe
vraiment
ils sont plusieurs
[Rires]
en fait
regarde me donner la peau ça n'est pas
jean charles c'est jean-michel
deux personnes
enlevées
deux personnes voilà une personne
discrète